okay I want to now do a little bit of a
deep dive into a recent poll this is an
utterly devastating poll for Donald
Trump with the normal caveats it's May
things can change very quickly between
now and November look at how quickly
they changed for Joe Biden within 72
hours after the South Carolina primary
now there is a Fox News poll that says
Trump is losing forty eight to forty two
Joe Biden right now I know some of you
will say David a Fox News poll what the
hell are you doing that that's crazy
Fox News why do we care Fox News polling
is its own enterprise they are well
ranked as far as polling goes and they
were pretty accurate back in 2016
538 ranks two different Fox News polling
partnerships as in either a - or a /b so
Fox News polling is actually pretty
reliable it's very different than what
you hear on their airwaves on the
question of Trump versus Biden
nationally Joe Biden has an eight-point
lead forty eight to forty Trump is
winning among men and Trump is winning
among whites losing a ton of other
important split so Trump is losing women
to Joe Biden Trump is losing black and
Hispanic voters Trump is losing all
non-white voters Trump is losing people
under 45 Trump is losing people over 45
Trump is losing people earning under
$50,000 a year and people earning more
than $50,000 a year but there's
something really interesting when you
look at some of the other splits
according to this poll four percent of
Democrats plan to vote for Trump and
eight percent of Republicans plan to
vote for Biden understand that if 2016
essentially holds with the one change of
four percent of Democrats abandoned the
Democratic Party in vote Trump eight
percent of Republicans abandoned Trump
and vote for Joe Biden that's all you
need to flip a bunch of states I'll give
you just one example we're gonna use
Hillary and Trump 2016 numbers to think
about this
so in Wisconsin in 2016 Hillary Clinton
lost by just under twenty three thousand
votes each candidate got about 1.4
million votes Trump just over 1.4
million clean
just under 1.3 million so this is very
simple math you take 4% of Hillary's
votes from 2016 and assigned them to
Trump you take 8% of trumps votes and
imagine that they went to Hillary or you
know potentially they would go to Joe
Biden that alone would have given
Hillary Clinton a ninety one thousand
vote victory in Wisconsin instead of a
loss so that is just one state it is
just one example but understand this
idea that we basically maintain 2016 if
four percent of Democrats switch and
eight percent of Republicans switch
Trump loses Trump loses now I want to
make it again
I know people said David what a you know
these disclaimers maybe aren't necessary
they are necessary right now we have a
long way to go this is a snapshot of
right now if the perception of the
economy improves by November if the
perception of how things are going with
coronavirus improves by November we may
very very quickly see this these numbers
reverse dramatically we must all vote we
must all get out the vote etc lastly
just one other thing on issues Trump is
always in these polls strongest on the
economy Trump is still stronger than
Biden on the economy in this latest Fox
News poll but it's by a far narrower
margin than we've seen throughout
Trump's presidency lastly on China
Trump in great part ran not just on I'll
fix the economy even though the economy
was doing quite well when Trump was
running Trump ran on I know how to deal
with China I know how to deal with trade
right now Joe Biden is polling as more
trustworthy on China that is one of
Trump's primary issues alongside this
amorphous all-encompassing economic
issues that he tends to do well on those
issue based numbers are very very
important let me know what you think
make sure you are subscribed to the
daily David Pakman show audio podcasts
get it on iTunes stitcher or any podcast
app that you prefer we'll be back after
this with some interest
videos to play for you some interesting
tweets and much more if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blinka stinketh lets you consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic
to check it out on blinkin blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video